um I think that it really depends on um
franchises and there's too many good
examples out there to mess this up at
this point you know like I think last of
us is a great one Sonic did a good job
yeah they realize they realize where um
the fans are fervent for lore and I
think you can't you can't deviate from
the lore that we know and the things
that we like for certain aspects
detective Pikachu fantastic idea of like
do whatever you want man like we have an
idea of what this might be and then do
whatever you want you're not touching a
thing that is like like a hot you know
like like a scar but something like Halo
something like last of us something that
that has evoked emotion I think that is
the thing that you can't touch too much
cuz it it is it's deep rooted in uh
players